how's the father life going
it's gnarly
would you say two or three is the worst
year because sometimes they say they're
terrible too but I actually think three
is the really treacherous year as a
father those three is when they're
really [__] yeah you used to be
it used to be like this real a lot of
real cuteness yeah you know a little
terrorist living with you you're a
little devil aren't you oh yeah
I still love you a lot but damn you know
you're a little devil definitely
potty training
it's cool I'm just gonna say that have
you have you had your son pee or [__] on
you on accident yet yeah yeah me too
yeah and not your son my son did that to
me when he was little man the the
[__] and why you why are you trying
to bathe them is the the craziest [__]
at least but at least that's like that's
kind of like nice
these are already in bathing position
you're already in bathing position
yeah it's a little you know [__]
floating uh how was the tour 54 dates
yes it felt like you guys were on tour
from like was it like July to October or
some [__]
was that exactly right look at me
knowing a lot about y'all
[Laughter]
yeah it was uh it was actually
lit as [__] it looked like it man it was
it was super lit every night like ended
being the most random places we'd be
like what the hell it's a lying down it
would just be crazy I feel like last
year you kind of got like right like
kind of back to where you were in terms
of dropping and shooting videos doing
your thing was it nice to kind of get
that reaffirmation from the fans on the
road yeah because like during covert and
during the like that that time period
where I was first starting to get off
hard drugs and stuff
I really wasn't making no music and like
there was no inspiration there you know
I'd be at home changing diapers with my
son you feel me you couldn't go anywhere
so it was like the the spark of
creativity just wasn't there and I was
just working on myself so you feel me
from to go from that time period and
then to be able to you know put music
out that I've been waiting to put out
you know and see what the reaction would
be that was a that was like
awesome like like okay we still got it
we back in it you know what I'm saying
we just had to take some time off and
that's okay you know what I'm saying